alright fellow Guardians the dawning is
out the winter event for Destiny's rise
of iron obviously you know srl is backs
barrow racing lead you got the vanguard
elite you can earn medals now in the
strike playlist ever vs. back of course
with new armor new ornaments new
treasures and just in general there's
you know some new quality of life stuff
greens will dismantle automatically at
level 40 you have new strikes including
you know the Nexus mine on the gold
tanukhs perfected and you strike scoring
system and new returning exotics the
Avedon Fire Lord and the Nova mortis
which is the void Lord as well as ice
breaker the two heavy machine guns that
I mentioned are just elemental plays off
of thunder lord so let's get into it
alrighty looking a pretty festive here
obviously to been redone for the winter
update we've got SR l's back all the
flags are flying which is awesome you
got that crazy snowflake gem type
looking thing over there let's let's
just check out our reverse test probably
has some new goodies for us let's see
what then take a look at what she's got
I have no silver which is you know not
so great there's a new shader sunglow
that looks pretty cool looks pretty much
like the colors that the tower would
have white and blue there's also a new
sparrow look a nice looking nice
alrighty what uh we got some new emotes
of course you got the suave dance
not bad not bad we got thunder dance
got the tiny dance okay let's check out
the emotes no you didn't Oh grace will
sneeze oh my god is that the dab that's
got to be the dab all right where's cam
newton you got pew pew mmm put them away
too hot mix it up you churn it stir it
up
[Music]
oh the John Cena you can't see me I
gotta see it again show to me again
nananana all right ah and we got a field
goal looks like it's good okay what else
do we got these are old right are they
old yeah these are their old so yeah
decent decent stuff there we of course
have some new quests I believe from mr.
Zavala apparently I'm still contacting
destiny servers which is also always fun
they're supposed to be new kiosk to with
ornaments i believe already mr. Zavala
across the system our enemies only we
gotta do the shadow thief strike it
appears then God would call on you once
again see that it gets done we also need
to do a vanguard weekly elite bounty in
any of the rising up iron strike
playlists I know alright so he has new
strike bounties which is good for PvE
obviously um earn gold tier silverchair
ok so these are the medals medals earn a
gold tier and nightfall before the time
expires and earned primary special in
heavy streak medals but I want to do
heavy machine gun for that then see if
there's any bounties we can pick up ok
there's new vanguard elite bounties now
on top of your normal just bounties earn
assists checking get three rapid kills
with any weapon tight it kills Anna seva
pressure strike to ern respective super
kills complete strikes the exact up we
need to clear out some some of my old
bounties to get more just fine we just
gotta pop some legendary mark ones
already special kills 150 kills all
right so they're really leaning in on
the metals and what not to try to get
you to obviously keep playing which is a
pretty cool I mean they've brought back
the strikes and stuff or enhance some of
the strikes alright let's go check out
srl wing even got it on the window panes
now there's two new maps which will now
make it so that you have four maps total
for srl already
over here Sparrow Racing's been
happening since all right earn your
c-class license up of course is four of
them it's not about the sparrow it's
about the racer right Guardian can make
a pile of junk lie like it sir all
you'll get a treasure box that's good
which means we probably got to get rid
of some of these old bounties here pop
this even though I'm not going to get
the full benefit this kind of sucks
that's a lot of Vanguard rep though all
right we'll just get rid of this crotas
bein one not a big deal alrighty we'll
pick up all our srl quests maybe sweet
take care guardian okay so this is the
silver dust or here we go this is I
think this is the new ornaments um yeah
okay so you can buy the ornaments now
you're still expensive 25 but at least
you can get the ones you want which is
cool apparently you can also buy
sparrows I'm already preview the
treasure boxes so the treasure boxes
have I think these are the new dawning
homes are wait no sorry these are yeah
so this is a new armor that you could
get this is the helm of lamentation
[Music]
looks okay
[Music]
the chest
the gloves
kind of looks like a like pretty casual
older set kind of thing and nothing too
fancy with this set that you can
guaranteed one of these things there's
also a bunch of sparrows that you can
get who that one's pretty cool Firefly
changes colors we got the bit fire these
some of these maybe you could get before
I'm not sure I never got them before so
probably just new sparrows kind of mix
up the look and Sparrow racing league
here's the kingdom's touch that all gold
one looks very nice
where is the phantasm I kind of like the
other sparrow look more than these ones
personally but you know to each their
own probably all handled differently to
I haven't really been looking at all of
the boost and went on
and this prismatic ax look at that how
it's pretty sweet so those are the
things you're guaranteed one of here is
the icebreaker ornament icebreaker
ornament got black spindle the taken one
I think is this one cold between stars
that one's pretty cool-looking you got
thorn thorn last word finally got its a
ornaments in as well as the Red Death
then you have a chance for the dawning
armor which looks pretty crazy to be
honest I had enough silver I'd probably
try to get some but you know just got
pretty pretty cool design on it check
out the shoulder the shoulders are
actually kind of small but cool design
on the the armors yeah pretty cool so
those are possible for you to get just
look at the draw if you get those
obviously take a look at the class armor
as well so pretty cool pretty cool stuff
we can't preview these Helms or like
they're not homes it's kind of like the
jack-o'-lanterns you consume them and
they turn your head into a different
color and for some reason they're given
chroma again and then all these these
horns so that's kind of a quick tour of
the the dawning at least in the tower
we'll go ahead and do some gameplay
stuff in terms of the strikes and
whatnot but uh yeah thank you guys for
tuning into a tour of the tower don't
forget to you know get into banner fall
where we'll show you how to get that
ghost and then get that secret treasure
I'm sure there's other gifts lying
around but that's the one I know of good
luck guardians and I hope you guys have
a fun time with the Donnie lasts from
today until January the third
[Music]